Yeah,
when we bought discovery it was in
terrible shape
and the first priority was to turn the
magazine around and three,
capture the sense of excitement and it
had say 10 and even 20 years ago and the
web was there,
but we let it lie fallow for a bit what
we fixed the magazine.
This is important because I wanted the
magazine to have its own personality and
energy DNA first.
Then I wanted the web to capture that
and I wanted it to grow into its own,
its own personality,
which was far more immediate news.
You know,
science news happens fast.
It's regulatory when it happens.
And most of all,
I thought the people who had made a
discovery will be most gushing to talk
about it right at that time.
So I wanted us to involve a lot more,
um,
scientists and I took the va with.
You may have read this in some of the
precedents.
I'm that scientists are rockstars in
many ways.
They're rock stars near community.
There's certainly rock stars in their
own heads.
Let me tell you from personal
experience.
And uh,
they have a lot to say.
Of course,
whenever they say it is brilliant and
fascinating,
I mean this is where sometimes the
analogy diverge just because not that
many rock stars of that fascinating when
they,
uh,
opened up,
but every scientist is and every
scientist has a great sense of humor.
By the way,
that's something I,
I,
I tried to make sure we had some human
that website.
So a strategy with the web was same as
it'll be with any magazine I run is be
the personality of the core product,
but have your own personality develop
your own life because people consume the
internet differently.
They consume print.
I mean the same person at the same time
will shift from one to another but
consume it in different ways in the same
way that a smart person will follow the
Financial Times and watch espn within
the same 20 minute span.
You know,
W,
w we do approach things differently.
And I thought that the media,
uh,
on the web needed to be more immediate
and more all encompassing and less of
just sort of archived articles.
My first advice would have been that the
print magazine had gone off its rails
and it failed to recognize
that times have changed.
It was no longer a novelty to see erotic
pictures.
I'm forget the fact that you can see
pictures in motion on the Internet.
That wasn't it.
It was the novelty and the need to see
it and long gone.
My father started that magazine not long
after,
and hefner started exactly around the
time the national geographic was
considered erotic because it printed
nude tribal women from Africa.
And so you put it in context.
That's where this stuff came from.
It arrives in the post aids age of the
mid eighties when it's just,
it's just not new.
Uh,
not new in a graphic way,
something like maximum and loaded before
it.
In England,
these things were new.
They were sexy,
they were sourcey.
They were cheeky,
but they had editorial about the rest of
men's interest as the dominant part of
the magazine.
And I think penthouse needed to shift in
that direction.
Maximum should never have come along.
Panel should have usurped it.
I'm now the web nonetheless.
It's clearly an awful lot of people
going to see it run a system on the web
panels could have provided that I think,
and I don't think it needed to have gone
as hardcore as it did because I think it
sort of stained the overall company.
I would take the magazine very mild,
a far more,
more fun,
Allah maximum or a loaded.
Um,
and I would have,
um,
taken the web to be whatever,
almost subscription,
whatever people wanted a,
you know,
again,
you're asking me to advise my dad,
which I really desperately wanted to do.
Post facto.
It's not important.
We've had some of discussions.
He agrees with someone that doesn't
agree with a lot of it.
And uh,
my old man's a genius.
So where he doesn't agree with me,
I,
I wonder maybe,
maybe he's so something I did.